aus und vorbei das ende der
internationalen raumstation iss ist
besiegelt eine ära der raumfahrt geht zu
ende die us-weltraumbehörde nasa will
die raumstation in den pazifik stürzen
lassen wie und wann genau wird die
station aufgegeben und was passiert
danach klick zum science in future hier
gibt es da mal pro woche spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen es ist traurig und
tragisch es ist soweit die ära der
internationalen raumstation iss wird
bald ein ende finden die
us-weltraumbehörde nasa hat ihre pläne
dazu vorgestellt es wird aber auch zeit
immer wieder kommt es zu problemen
defekten und verschleiß erscheinungen
und das ist kein wunder denn die alte
dame hat ihre besten zeiten hinter sich
einige ihrer module wurden noch zu
sowjetzeiten gebaut also vor mehr als 30
jahren seit mittlerweile 24 jahren also
seit dem jahr 1998 ist die iss im
betrieb und seit 22 jahren seit dem jahr
2000 leben und arbeiten raumfahrern und
raumfahrt- und sie hat bei vielen für
begeisterung gesorgt so zum beispiel
auch beim deutschen raumfahrer alexander
gerst er hatte vor vier jahren 2018 von
der ss getwittert die komplexeste
wertvollste und unwahrscheinlichste
maschine die die menschheit jemals
gebaut hat zum wohle aller jetzt steht
ihre beerdigung an geplant noch zu ihren
lebzeiten ein tragisches ende dabei war
ihre geburt ein signal des aufbruchs und
des friedens denn so unterschiedliche
partner sind bei ihrem start dabei
gewesen alleine fünf raumfahrt
organisationen und damit 16 nationen
sind beteiligt darunter die usa russland
deutschland frankreich kanada japan sie
war nach dem ruf von einer sowjetischen
raumkapsel sojus und einer
amerikanischen apollo kapsel 1975 die
erste zusammenarbeit des westens mit den
russen quasi das offizielle ende des
kalten krieges also schon sehr symbol
schon mal sah 82 hatten die usa mit der
space station task force die planung
begonnen in deren verlauf mehr als
deutlich wurde dass eine nation alleine
diese station nicht aus der taufe heben
konnte um das kind auf die welt zu
bringen brauchte es mehrere beteiligte
und mit diesen nationen konnte die
stationen dann endlich nach mehr als 15
jahren planung und bau stück für stück
ins all geschickt werden am 20 november
1998 war es soweit mit einer russischen
proton rakete wurde das fracht und
antriebs modul sarja in eine umlaufbahn
gebracht und dann wurde die station wie
ein puzzle stück für stück modul für
modul zusammen gebaut das letzte modul
wurde erst im november letzten jahres
gebracht dass andockmodul trittschall
nach mehr als 30 jahren
doch jetzt wurde ihr ende besiegelt laut
einer vereinbarung von 2014 könnte die
iss bereits in zwei jahren
2024 beerdigt werden und das ist
wirklich so eine so riesige station muss
nach ihrem ende möglichst schnell aus
der umlaufbahn entfernt werden sollte
sie mit einem satelliten oder ähnlichem
kollidieren wäre das mit dem neu
entstandenen weltraummüll eine absolute
katastrophe und könnte eine
kettenreaktion
auslösen wird ihr betrieb eingestellt
ist dass auch das finale todesurteil der
station dabei hat sie zu so vielen
erkenntnissen führt und eine
verlängerung bis an die grenzen der
möglichkeiten ist von vielen seiten
gewünscht die nasa hat jetzt aktuelle
pläne dazu vorgestellt wie es mit der
iss weitergehen wird demnach bleiben er
noch einige jahre doch dann folgt ihre
unausweichliche beerdigung er abstürzt
und ein ende auf dem friedhof der
raumfahrzeuge welche pläne die nasa
genau verfolgt und wie es danach
weitergeht all diese spannende infos und
noch viel mehr bekommt er jetzt hier von
mir ja es ist ein echter koloss ist 109
meter lang der innenraum so groß wie ein
jumbo jet ihrer fläche vergleichbar mit
einem fußballfeld zudem ist sie
gigantische 24 tonnen schwer in ihrer
geschichte brachten diese dimensionen
tatsächlich viele nachteile mit sich
denen die station zeigte sich zu
unflexibel zu groß und vor allem als
unfassbar 100 milliarden euro hat sie
bisher gekostet unter anderem ein grund
für ihre mächtigen dimensionen die iss
war zur zeit ihrer entstehung spannender
weise gar nicht wirklich als eine
wissenschafts station gedacht damals
ging es um eine reine machtdemonstration
von seiten des westens ihre entstehung
hat damit also eher eine politische
wirkung geplant wurde sie in den 80er
jahren erstmals nur als projekt des
westens und dann änderte sich alles und
aus der machtdemonstration wurde durch
die beteiligung der russen ein projekt
des friedens ein politisches signal zu
zeiten des kalten krieges zu zeiten
ihres baus war außerdem überhaupt nicht
von einem langzeitaufenthalt immer
ausgegangen worden dort planen sollten
die module der als es maximal 15 jahre
im einsatz sein doch das erklärt die
zahlreichen technischen effekte der
vergangenheit wer hat man ja immer
wieder darüber berichtet im vergangenen
jahr 2021 beispielsweise hatte das
russische modul auch die iss erreicht
und zunächst schien alles glatt zu gehen
doch dann fingen die probleme an das
modul hatte erneut die triebwerke
aktiviert obwohl das fest mit der iss
verbunden war und das ohne jegliche
vorwarnung die gesamte station drehte
sich dadurch mehr als einmal um die
eigene achse weitere russische
triebwerke die sich automatisch
aktiviert hatten stemmten sich mit
voller kraft dagegen nokia war vom boden
nicht zu erreichen ein ehemaliger nasa
mitarbeiter hatte das ganze scharf
kritisiert kritik kommt auch von seiten
russlands im modul sarja wurden bei
einer kontrolle risse gefunden der
flugdirektor des russischen teils des
programms wladimir solowjow verwies
zudem auf frühere warnungen die er
ausgesprochen hatte demnach könnte die
alternde technik der ice es nach 2025
eine wahre lawine an effekten auslösen
dann könnte im schlimmsten fall sogar
aus dem oberflächlichen rissen luft
entweichen russlands raumfahrtbehörde
roskosmos gibt sich lange bedeckt und
beschwichtigte immer wieder wurde betont
dass es keine unmittelbare gefahr für
die besatzung auf der ice es gebe doch
auch andere fachleute weltweit waren sie
sind sich sicher dass es mit der als es
zu ende geht so beispielsweise auch der
russische kosmonaut gennadi padalka alle
module des russischen teils sind ab wie
lange also hält die raumstation noch aus
noch weitere zwei jahre bis zum jahr
2020 wie 2014 vereinbart oder
möglicherweise sogar bis 2028 oder noch
länger die us-raumfähre hat jetzt pläne
dazu bekannt gegeben demnach soll die
internationale raumstation iss erst im
januar 2000 31 also in neun jahren zum
absturz gebracht werden dann ist also
endgültig schluss dieser wirklich
unglaublichen erfolgsgeschichte fast 40
jahre hat die station auf dem buckel und
dass es für eine solch unglaubliche
aufwendige maschine der absolute
wahnsinn im weltraum das hatte man zu
beginn noch für unmöglich gehalten dass
eine solche station so lange halten kann
das ist schon der absolute wahnsinn und
da muss man wohl den hut vor der alten
dame ziehen dass sie es so lange
geschafft hat wow doch schon in wenigen
jahren mitte des jahrzehnts soll ihre
umlaufbahn langsam abgesenkt werden den
plänen zufolge soll sie dann zum
jahreswechsel 2030 31 so weit abgesunken
sein dass eine rückkehr ausgeschlossen
ist der beginn ihrer letzten reise nur
wenige tage später soll sie in den
südpazifik stürzen eine region die
tausende kilometer von dem nächsten
menschlichen siedlungen entfernt liegt
und damit das risiko sehr gering ist
dass sie über besiedelten gebiet
niedergeht auf wird dieses gebiet auch
als weltraum friedhof bezeichnet nur
hier können große objekte aus dem
weltraum gefahrlos entsorgt werden
konkret handelt es sich um die region
mit dem namen point nemo der pazifische
pohl der unzugänglichkeit dieser ort ist
tatsächlich die stelle auf der erde die
am weitesten vom festland und sämtlichen
inseln entfernt ist hier wurden schon
mehrere hundert raumschiffe versenkt so
beispielsweise auch die russische
raumstation mir im jahr 2001 wichtig ist
die richtige positionierung der
raumstation dann folgt ein letztes
kommando aus dem kontrollzentrum so dass
eine wiedereintritt zündung gestartet
wird dadurch wird die raumstation so
tief wie möglich abgesenkt dann gibt es
quasi nichts mehr zu tun denn die
schwerkraft der erde erledigt den rest
und besiegelt das ende der ss die
raumstation wird weiter nach unten in
richtung erde ziehen das unausweichliche
ende beim eintritt in die erdatmosphäre
wird ein großer teil der hss verglühen
die restlichen teile sollen dann
kontrolliert über dem südpazifik
abstürzen und eben im raumschiff
friedhof beerdigt werden als grund dafür
das ende der station nun endgültig zu
besiegeln führt die nasa vor allem den
zustand der zentralen struktur der
raumstation an das sind die hunde mann
und module mit technik und einer
gitterstruktur zur stabilisierung dem
bericht zufolge könnten alle anderen
teile repariert werden doch hier sei das
nicht der fall im falle eines problems
sind sie nur schwer zugänglich spricht
im raumanzug kommt man im zweifel gar
nicht an die entsprechenden stellen
haben die jeweiligen raumfahrtagenturen
von japan europa und kanada hatten sich
bereits um den zustand einzelner module
gekümmert und diesen analysiert demnach
sei man auch hier bis 2028 sich russland
befindet sich noch in der prüfung die
nasa geht in ihrem aktuellen bericht
davon aus dass bis ins jahr 2030 alles
glatt laufen wird somit könnte die
letzte crew im frühjahr 2030 an bord der
iss kommt wie es in dem nasa schreiben
heißt das ende der ss bedeutet für die
us raumfahrtagentur nasa in zukunft
einen warmen geldsegen schätzungen
zufolge könnten dadurch allein im jahr
2031 ganze 1,3 milliarden us dollar
eingespart werden im jahr 2033 könnte
der sparbetrag sogar 1,8 milliarden us
dollar betragen auf die nutzung da es
bis zum ende auf dem orange friedhof ist
in dem aktuellen bericht ein thema dazu
robin givens die iss direktorin im
nasa-hauptquartier die internationale
raumstation geht in ihr drittes und
produktivste jahrzehnt als bahnbrechende
wissenschaftliche plattform in der
schwerelosigkeit
demnach werde man in diesem jahrzehnt
die erforschung des weltraums
unterstützen der menschheit weiterhin
zitat medizinische und ökologische
vorteile bieten und den zitat grundstein
für eine kommerzielle zukunft im
erdnahen orbit leben fest steht
jedenfalls die besuchsliste für die iss
ist lang durch die korrekten raumkapseln
von spacex sind die usa nach dem ende
des space shuttle programms in der lage
wieder selbst astronautinnen astronauten
ins all zu transportieren
diese transportkapazitäten sollen
vermehrt auch von weltraum touristinnen
und touristen genutzt werden nachdem
ende da ss möchten die usa selbst keine
teure raumstation mehr im erdorbit
betreiben statt dessen sollen
kommerzielle angebote genutzt werden
genau dieser übergang von der ss hin zur
kommerziellen station soll bis zum jahr
2030 klappen die nasa schreibt dazu in
einer mitteilung es ist das ziel der
nasa einer von vielen kunden dieser
kommerziellen anbieter zusammen nur die
güter und dienstleistungen zu kaufen die
die behörde benötigt schon vor zwei
jahren hatte die nasa einen vertrag mit
dem us-unternehmen extreme space
abgeschlossen vorgesehen ist der bau
eines bewohnbaren moduls das an die iss
angedockt wird zudem unterstützt die
nasa drei weitere unternehmen finanziell
bei der entwicklung von entwürfen für
raumstationen diese sollen wenigstens
zum teil bereits genutzt werden können
bevor die beerdigung der ss bevorsteht
auch wenn diese raum statt zum privat
betrieben werden sollen sollen sie der
nasa und anderen staatlichen kunden
offen stehen die nasa selbst
konzentriert sich dann verstärkt auf die
rückkehr zum mond und auf weitere ziele
die noch weiter von der erde entfernt
sind zum beispiel der maas so wird der
mast zu erde terraforming mit
künstlichen magnetfeld anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das kostenlos
und geht ja ganz einfach mit dem abo
button unter jedem video also ich zähle
auf euch bis dann bleibt an